and to the community and recreation
budgets chris so
um perhaps you want to walk us through
how you want to manage your budgets and
introduce your team at various times and
we can go through go through your um
budgets as
they come along so you're i assume
you're starting
according to our list it was going to be
with libraries but we'll leave that with
you and you
you may wish to handle it differently
i'll just go well it's page 420 but i'll
just wait to you for christmas if we can
do
the stadium uh management financial
assistance report first
um paul is just going to turn up uh any
minute
and then we can move on to libraries i
assume we're doing reports
first well we can if you'd like to do it
deal with it that way for each area
yeah reports for each area followed by
the budget for each area um would be
ideal
okay so um just re refresh us the report
on uh
it's uh tab 13 item 411 then you're um
i'm diligent does everyone got that up
don't just give them a couple of minutes
304 and and you're diligent
i use the tabs does anyone else use the
teams yeah
yeah yep so
okay has everyone got on the right tab
on the right page
all right chris thank you uh so this
report
is seeking council approval for
financial assistance to the north canada
sport and recreation trust
and to assist in the establishment costs
of operating the stadium so we've been
working with
the trust for quite some time on the
memorandum of understanding which
council
has approved which looks at currently
a rent relief essentially
a staged rent provided to the council
over three years starting at 50 and 75
in the full um after three years and
that gives them a bleeding period
essentially to get the building up and
running the trust approached us and said
well that's really really good and they
really like that approach they do have
um some upfront costs which they're
going to need to cover um to actually
operate the building
so at the moment they're out recruiting
an hr
manager and also a manager for the
actual building itself in april we start
with the training
of someone from north carolina sport
recreation trust on on how to actually
operate the building
they need to be able to turn the lights
on when they walk in on day one we can't
just hand them the keys
so to employ someone they obviously have
an upfront cost
and it's going to start around and
around april this year uh the trust came
to us
originally said they wanted around 130
000 this report
suggests that we give them rent relief a
further rent relief in that first year
of 60 000
um the reason for the change between 60
and 130 that the trust actually
requires and will likely have to cover
is that we would like to offer the 6d
and then the trust is going to to cash
flow the rest
they're going to come back after the
first year and obviously as they admit
to in their memory of understanding show
us their books if they're doing really
really well
they may be able to cover it if they're
not doing really really well
then they may have to come back and ask
for further assistance to cover that
upfront cost that they're going to have
to pay now
we didn't want to give them all of it up
front just in case they're doing really
well
and they can cover it themselves i'm
happy to take any questions
thanks chris any questions
okay well um
there's a recommendation counselor
reading your question
um i take a question that you think it's
better to give them a rent reduction
rather than the grant for that amount
yeah there's a number of options within
the report and it discusses those
those options um we did talk to the
trust about the rent relief
um or potentially giving them a grant
or reducing the one million dollar
capital contribution that they have
or paying for it out of our um or paying
for the grind out of our contingency we
don't think there'll be contingency left
at this stage um however there might be
um that depends so um
the it's it's six or one half a dozen in
the uh of the other really um as to
exactly how they end up
um getting the sixty thousand dollars
they were happy with the rent relief um
which is
direct income for for them because they
don't have to pay that uh that to us or
the grant so
they'd be happy with with each option
okay
uh council williams you have a question
yeah originally when the deal was
getting done
they were talking about fundraising and
what they were going to sell
some of the assets to help cover this
and i noticed some of their assets
they would had actually told us they're
going to sell they haven't even bothered
to try to sell
it's um that's not korean and it's not
correct so if you're if you're referring
to
uh east belt yeah they're currently um
sorry i'm
referring to um uh edward street edward
street yeah
that was what i was referring to yeah
the other one we all knew what we knew
about that
yeah um they do actually they are going
through their process at the moment
uh so i had a meeting with ice
trampolining
uh yesterday or the day before and ice
street bleeding and gymnastics are going
through a process at the moment to
hopefully merge together which is really
really
a good outcome and they still have the
offer
of purchasing that so i was talking to
them yesterday around
um how they were potentially going to
fund that
in terms of purchase they've got a time
frame that the trust has given them to
come up with a sale and purchase
agreement
if they don't come up the sale and
purchase agreement then the trust is
going to put that on the open market
so if that gets on the open market this
amount will get refunded to the council
is that correct
uh no um no no no it doesn't the the
trust
still need to fund their fit out and
they need to fund the million dollars
that they're going to look to provide us
so the trust at the moment has been
successful and obtaining
five hundred thousand dollars from
lotteries three hundred thousand dollars
from rata
i do believe that they've sold their
gold um
uh fundraising um and then now they're
looking for silver
and bronze so so they are doing all
right with their fundraising but they
need that money themselves to operate
and they need their money
um for for staff and for their own fit
out as well so
this is over and above um and chris you
might just want to perhaps sit over the
naming right sponsor which has been
agreed
and um for a number of in some of the
courts as well
and you're aware of what the yeah so
around us so
then the naming are not 100 sure on the
figures
um but yeah they've got the naming right
sponsor and then they've actually got
the court sponsorship as well
that's enough debate on this topic
yeah it's actually a natural calling
um way of the building saying yes
all right further questions uh
councilman
um chris just wondering do you have an
opening date for the stadium is it on
time
and what part in 21 22 is it opening
uh it should be open in august i believe
it's on track i went ahead a visit last
week
all the flooring is on site and all the
the jibbing of the walls and things is
all done so it actually looks quite good
now
the one thing which we're waiting on the
is the
rubber flooring inside the gym room so
that's the the one thing which is coming
from spain at the moment
and you know if worse case scenario it
doesn't come and we open the whole
building
and the gym part which is the trust part
is delayed slightly but the actual four
courts and all the other
auxiliary buildings will be finished and
ready to open so
cool so so even if august slid into
september so that's three months of the
year that
hasn't been able to be used so
technically is that that would be about
75
of the rental which would be 75 000
anyway so would we normally give a
partial
rental if people can't use the building
that's not open yeah that's
uh yeah that's i mean we're using we are
giving rental relief yeah
for that first year to reflect the fact
that on day one they're not likely to
have a full and you're right on day one
and financial year it
thank you christian and notwithstanding
what you've just said about the opening
dates and things
uh why was this cost not identified
before now how
how do we get it now and it's this
amount of money
and um it wasn't identified before
because we must have known that the
building was
going to be opening was going to have a
period where it's going to take a long
time to build up and all those things
what was it not a bigfoot
i think it's been a complete oversight
to be fair other trusters approached
justin said look
with the current financial arrangements
that we've got we need to start bleeding
money and
in terms of getting staff in to actually
start operating the building and
we don't have an income from the
building so what are we going to do
about it
and they said look we've got a number of
options we'd like to explore the council
in terms of rent relief or grants to get
us up and running
so that's how this report came about we
uh
not being fully understanding of the way
in which the trust was going to operate
the building
um this didn't spring up for craig or or
myself
and it was something that trust came to
us and said look we've now got our
contracts ready to go and start a
recruitment process to employ someone
early
how are we going to pay for that and how
are we going to cover it so are we
satisfied then that going forward that
the right
plans are in place and that they do
actually know how to be able to do those
things
as as staff we are um they do have
experience in doing this uh obviously
with their bid street building
um they are um doing the right thing in
terms of making sure that they are
employing
um the right people in terms of a
manager for the building but also um
that hr support as well to make sure
that their contracts are right
we know that they've already been
getting contracts drawn up for the likes
of the health services part of the
building as well
um so so they're actually doing quite a
lot at the moment using their existing
staff
so we're confident um they've already
spoken to the likes of football and um
basketball and netball and already
pretty much uh locked them in in terms
of
how they want to use the building when
they want to use the building so they've
done a lot of work already
and so we're pretty confident they'll be
able to run it successfully
council award
um would it be
me put the question right
given that the the
contractors are on time and they've been
very very good
is it not reasonable to expect
that everything will be done on time and
that we're looking forward to the
opening function in late august for
business awards
that i cannot guarantee but would be
wonderful
okay any further questions
counselor yes
so are there going to be any other
surprises expected
um people's original one deal from
the ingredients yeah look um had i known
that this was going to be something for
consideration
it would have been here a lot earlier so
i can't crystal ball gaze on what might
come forward but we've been in constant
contact with the trust
on a daily basis around fit out of the
building around changes to the building
around their operation
we're pretty confident it won't be but
what we've done in this report is we
haven't given them 130 that they've
asked for
to reflect the fact that um you know we
don't know how this building is actually
going to
how successful it's going to be we know
that there's a lot of people who want to
rent it at the moment and we think it's
going to be really successful
so we said look let's let's just give
you the 16 hour then you can come with
your books open your books to us
next year and if you are doing really
really well better than expected then
then don't expect us to to give you more
money to cover those costs
um so we're doing it slowly um so that
we can we can um be very aware and
open-eyed going into this actually
intentionally it could be an ongoing
thing
um i'm i'm pretty confident that it will
be the other way
and that we won't have to give more um
but
okay the reality the reality is until
this has probably been running for 18
months two years will you actually know
where it's actually settled and landing
and how
the trusts are doing it the array the
conversation all the way through is it's
there's an element of unknown in this
they are the best operators of the of
the venue by a long shot
and in terms of the options we had in
front of them and we're going to need to
work with them to ensure that whatever
is the outcome is fair to both
and i think that should be the basis on
which we're thinking about how
how the facility operates in a manner
that we want them to run up to the best
of their ability to maximize their
utilization and occupancy
we want them to be successful in their
own business
we don't want to be cross-subsidizing
their business unnecessarily but we do
need to be fair in the arrangements and
i think
that should be how we think about it
over the next 18 months as
they get to learn what the facilities
potential is
and we get to understand how
successful or otherwise they are and we
are in the delivery of
the anticipated service
thank you so have we come to
recommendation you're going to move
council duty and
are you indicated you wish the second
council award you'd like to speak
obviously
that's all right all right well we'll
see if you still wish to speak soon
council duty thank you this this
is very important part of
getting the trust up and running to run
this business
successfully the trust has a lot of
professional people
on their board though they're certainly
um
really um proactive and forward thinking
um they want they haven't come to us
lightly with this that's been
something that they've worked through
they've done a lot of work on there
putting this together working out
exactly what needs to be done
um they've taken ownership of the
stadium
and everything else to go with it they
want to make sure
that it is a top-notch
performing stadium and
um they're trying to fit put all the um
the sports and the gym and all that and
on it
it's been a lot of work involved with
that they've got
a full compliment for most
days i think of the week for sporting
that wants to go
wants to be part of it so the and
it's most important that this whoever
they put on there that the staff
are highly competent on how this this
building is going to run
and it's very important for us
as councillors and for them as the
running of it
that it goes very smoothly so this is
why i am recommending
this um that we council
helps with the 60 000 towards the cost
of
running starting this stadium up and
running
councilwood thank you yes i'm really
want to support this option too to give
them support
to get underway i know they're highly
competent
and i know that this is going to be very
very successful
and a great asset to the community so i
thoroughly support this to
a hand a hand up and i'm sure that
that that we won't be asked to do too
many because i know it's going to be
very successful
counselor so i've got speaking last
council redmond myself then councillor
williams
has written thank you mr mayor i support
the
recommendation this is a very
well-run organisation and uh councillor
duty and myself are
your representatives on their trust
so i'm very much in favor of supporting
them
it's rather ironic because initially i
was not a supporter
of the stadium in terms of its timing
so anyhow i'm now an enthusiastic fan
and i think we really need to do
all we can to help the trust uh they
work very closely with the council so
they're not a loose unit running around
out there so i'm very supportive of
their
request thank you and i'm going to
support
the request today too um but when we
they first came to the table we were
talking about the lease
we did actually say we didn't want to
set them up to fail so that was the
conversation we had in the early stages
in around the amounts of money that we
set aside as the lease agreement that
was the sums that we
we agreed to but there is a lag period
that this organization also has been
affected by covert too
so they have been in a situation where
they've had loss of income
and i'm confident that they
are the right organisation to be running
this facility
they've already raised over a million
dollars
the the issue with trampoline uh and
um down there is it actually has taken
some time
in which to get to a point where they
can have that conversation
and that those organizations are in the
place in which to get space to consider
whether or not they wish to take over
that building or indeed buy it
and the trust didn't want to get on
because of the nature of what they do
didn't want to get ahead of themselves
and sell they could have easily sold the
building
um and could do very fairly well in the
current market but
actually is that advancing sport in the
in the area in general and it's not
it's better to work with those
organizations to see if a win-win can be
achieved in the trust
and the leadership of don robertson who
i think we're very lucky to have in that
space
with his business and commercial acumen
um brings a real rigor there
and i go to along to the working party
meetings as well and i'm very
i'm impressed with don and the
and the work that he's doing remembering
that he's also a volunteer and
most of the those that are there all the
trustees in there actually are
volunteers and there's a huge voluntary
aspect
there is paid staff that work through
the gyms and the other programs that the
trust put on but
remembering that we're a settler of this
it's an organization that we're involved
with with two trustees
they're coming to us with a realistic
proposal um and i think chris going
forward it
i expected this reaction today and
rightly so
uh from colleagues that it's probably a
fairly hard conversation back to trust
that we
not really expecting this to come back
again really but we don't i don't
necessarily want to set them up to farm
either but with the ford bookings that
they've got
confident from what i'm told that they
will be able to manage this well in fact
the fundraising's going better than
expected they bought in place caroline
whitaker
very impressive and we those of us that
were at the
naming rights
opening that day could see the level and
caliber of interest that they had there
of businesses in the community
and broadly who are right behind it so
once they get and it's taken them some
time to get that right now they've got
that model right
they've sold as chris said they've sold
all the gold
they're now looking at silver and bronze
and the other levels so
there'll be opportunities for each of us
should we wish to make contributions
i'm considering doing one myself
to assist because i think that that's
something that
i those of us who have supported the
building of the stadium over the years
i certainly want to see it succeed so
i'm doing
supporting this today is justice i think
just a short term
manner i don't think the trust we will
we will see but i doubt that they'll be
back here again because
it'll be up and running and the model
will be proved itself to be successful
so
urge you to support the recommendation
um
council witness yeah i also will be
supporting this because it's very
important that the
trust actually survives and is vibrant
i'm just a wee bit disappointed that
they have come back
so soon wanting a bit of a
handout to get things rolling and um
and what they hadn't and visit but um
it's going to be really good for the
community long term so i think we've
just got to support it and
i also hope they don't come back for
more and um
wanting the rate pass for a pop-up thank
you
yes it's always really good to look back
in hindsight and say oh we should have
done that and you know
there's something perhaps that we should
have done but hey it's happened and now
we've got the situation having the trust
for us is a huge advantage it costs will
cost us way more to run it ourselves
so we're actually saving the right
paying money by having a voluntary trust
helping to run this this um wonderful
facility
i noted that they're only going to have
it for three quarters of the year
so it would have only been a 75 000 rent
anyway so it's not even the full amount
that they're being asked for today
and we have given rent relief on other
council buildings
um during the covert period so i see no
problem in giving them the sum today
to help them get up and running and i
wish them all the best
thank you further speakers reply council
duty
thank you thank you very much i really
do ask you all to support this i've only
just got
to look at don robertson and
and how he runs everything and he's so
proactive the whole team the whole board
is so proactive
and they want to see the best and you've
and quite frankly you've only got to
look at how the new
south rock gym is at how is going
and just how efficiently it is
run and that's exactly how our
our um gymnasium and uh um
amazing i mean that i mean now our um
stadium will be and also when they get
the their new
facility up and running for um
sports people to to train in there at
this very high level
it's going to be a real asset for our
whole district
so i urge you all to support this
thank you okay well then i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say hi
contrary i'll declare that carrie do you
want that recorded
all right chris thank you
uh libraries libraries now
so well
so they're um white pa in our white
so we've got in our pages it's page 420
but we're going to cover
uh the supplementary agenda item
which was the um rengar civic precinct
meter first so that's the paper
on um so you need to go into your
diligent and it's in the
supplementary agenda
sorry has it been put in that's item 14
sorry
do you want to deal with the report
first or yeah
do the report first so that's
essentially that so that's in the
supplementary agenda
so everyone got that
go back go back out and and diligent
there was a um there was a couple of
copies of it floating around yesterday
actually
so just give me miss a minute to bring
it up
yes we're doing dealing with the civic
rengara civic precinct first
1.1 so that's and there's a
there's a report in diligence has
everyone got that up
okay so um chris and jay
so just as a reminder the uh the
original civic
precinct was sitting in year 11 when we
did the last ldp
in 2018 so effectively it's still
sitting in year
11 but now becomes year eight three
years on
um the reason for this report is to just
confirm
that the rationale for
coupling the library with that civic
center is still intact and
and part of that strategy so um
we and the reason for not bringing that
to back
you know and you know forward forward as
we were
going to do uh is that there's a number
of things that
central government is still deciding on
this main one is three waters
you also have uh resource consenting
and in addition to that is um with those
two activities going
there could even be a re-jiggle with
local authorities
as it stands today so not an
ideal situation but coupling these two
projects
as we found out when we did the
preliminary estimations
does provide substantial savings and
efficiencies when you look at the
operations of a
an organisation going forward in a
building that's going to last 50 years
plus
it also provided you know a good
relationship with the rendura town
centre strategy
so it's just putting us back in front of
the council just to
just to check whether our strategies
are right with the environment exist at
the moment
and i think chris is going to just talk
about
um the the sort of
the activities and um the way in which
that could be accommodated for the
next few years to um allow it to happen
so that the levels of service that we're
providing through the
library to the community has
been looked after thanks jeff so
we do have a library specific report
which we can
do after this and the library specific
report and some of the items which are
identified
in the library budget have been put in
there
to bridge the gap essentially and we've
got a number of items um which look to
modify the rengura treva branch memorial
library at the moment
to allow more space for library services
to
be more modern in the way that we
deliver those to our communities
you know the levels of service around
library provision
suggest that we actually need the
library space now we've needed more
library space around europe
for a number of years already we're
aware of that
as jeff has said coupling it with the
civic precinct
building um if you're a
pure library supporter 100 it's not
the best deal however when you look at
it from a council perspective a rate
payer perspective and if you look at it
long term and what the outcome is going
to be for our community
um it is something which um which i
think should be supported
um the costs and building one building
are lower and there are some synergies
between doing that and it also uses a
civic precinct in a far better way to
get a better outcome for the community
but it does obviously delay what is
currently a level of service need that
we have so
the rest of the library's budget paul
has done an amazing job of looking at
ways we can use the existing space
modify that space use technologies to be
able to bridge the gap between the
service
that we have now in the service we know
we should be providing to our community
so
uh we're in support of of the
recommendations and in this report
thank you uh any questions
councilman two questions what percentage
of the district used the rangiora
library
it used to be 65 but has that changed
i don't know if we have those figures at
the top of our of our head what we can
say is that
we do have a target of people through
the door
and that target has to beat the previous
year's target and we've always
been able to achieve that target so the
numbers are uh
550 600 000 through the door a year and
then it seems to grow with population so
i would imagine the
the ratio is probably about the same
being that um
people through the door is growing at
the same rate as um people
in the district we also have a
remarkably high
amount of people that actually take out
books from our library more so than some
other parts of the district which
probably reflects the demographic we
have
um second question is that the library
got pushed out because of the earthquake
and we had to focus resources everywhere
else and the civic precinct's been
pushed out by covert in other factors
um and now the so there's always going
to be something come up
and i have concerns the civic precinct
will actually never happen
in that situation couldn't there be some
sort of stage one planning for expansion
of the rangiora library earlier but
due to the fact that it is just not
meeting level of service
i think if local government changes
to a point where the civic precinct
extinctions would significantly have to
change
the number of staff and the organization
is a lot lower
none of that really changes the need for
the library to extend
i think at that point once those sorts
of things are a little bit more certain
um we can continue to work with the um
the architect that we that we already
have been working on on modifying
um the way in which the staff
accommodation was extended or not
extended but then look at
the library extension being the primary
project there so the
the focus of the project at the moment
is on both that's once we know more
about three waters more about local
government going forward we're going to
be able to
to move with that which could be could
end up being the library being the main
focus and an extension
solely just being the library extension
but at the moment it's just a little bit
too early and what we don't want to do
is
do a huge amount of um costly planning
and then potential building
um and get a result which is not going
to be um
long term 50 years so um but given that
the next
long-term plan is not until 2024
and this is pushing it out to 2027
wouldn't it be wiser to leave that
budget placeholder and a little bit
earlier
until we know more which is likely to be
in the next 12 to 18 months
at the moment we've combined the two
budgets if if council would like us to
look to bring the library back
we could do that i just don't think
we're going to be in a position even in
well we may be in a position and the
next long-term plan to make a decision
at the next long-term plan we have the
option of pulling that money back
um if we know more i think just further
to that i think
depends how the reform proposals
progress through parliament because i
think that's ultimately going to be
where
they will be progressed we we may be
back doing either a significant
amendment
to or a new ltp well in front of three
years
and so i think i think the issues that
could be in front of us
may be sufficiently significant to
warrant new ltps which could see
many elements of the council's business
and program
subject to further review
but so mr palmer why wouldn't we just
leave the budget provisions as they are
now
until we have that information um
because i
i think we are still wanting to do you
know
the current position well you could
argue the budget provision is where it
is now it was in year 11 it's now in
year eight
but the thought that um bringing
bringing
doing both projects together is still
the most sensible thing
to do for the combined complex
if we do bring it forward then
um two things will be a consequence of
that to bring that
because i think you would bring like if
you were minded to you'd bring both
projects forward in the budget provision
which will see both a rate implication
and a debt implication for the council
which
jeff i'm not sure if you're able to
comment on
oh it takes things to quite close to the
limit i think when the working party
were looking through this
and that's why that working party
sufficiently ceased it at that point of
time is that
it's not just the library and civic
centre
it's how that actually works and with
the
the town centre strategy and how it
promotes the township
and until you actually know what that
scope
of the building and size looks like and
and how the library would be
incorporated into that space
and get the efficiencies all working
it's very difficult to actually
build a building like that which you
could build a building
and then with the foresight of saying
well
if it doesn't happen this this extra
space could be commercial but even doing
that there's a huge amount of risk
that you're putting into that type of
build and
in the highly risky that you get it
wrong because it might not
be what the business wants to operate
from
so until that decision is made
we could you know quickly get that
project team together again
and get something moving but too much
risk
uh with in decisions coming through from
central government at the moment
okay any further questions do we have a
recommendation
i'll i'll move seeking the council award
there's been a as our staff have
mentioned a lot of thinking
going behind us there have been some
initial work
prepared it's all around what is
i guess what she's talked about is being
responsible and prudent but also
looking at the climate we're in there is
it's been signaled by government there's
a lot of potential change
coming and we know that the three water
space has certainly governed its very
firm desire
so in terms of bill i do think it makes
sense to have
and it is considered as one because
there are
uh cost efficiencies that can be
achieved the other thing i'd like to
consider and this is not just about the
library but
we're also talking about museum as well
so it is a genuine precinct and look at
park car parking potential as well in
fact some of the
designs that some the architects have
come up with had some fairly creative
solutions
it just became clear that when we're
looking at costings it's going to be
significantly more than is even
indicated here
um and we don't know that until uh
that's properly looked at and at the
moment i don't think that's the right
time to be signaling personally
to the community that we're looking at
that level of expenditure
when our community is particularly
hurting with kobe
um there are a lot of people that have
either lost their jobs or under reduced
hours
there's a whole degree of
uncertainty and i pick that up every day
when i'm out and about
and i'm sure others of you uh do as well
so it's about being prudent
in us also looking at the appropriate
timing knowing what this
what the size of our business is looking
like um
and as we said you know we're likely to
be facing a
an earlier long-term plan revision than
we otherwise anticipated
if things change we can look at this at
any time
and we can pull this board if we feel
that that's right or we can look at
staging and we could look at heading to
the library
at that point as is mentioned that it's
the right thing to do is to look at the
complete conflicts i appreciate look i'd
love
ideally to be doing the whole thing and
getting it done once and for all
it's very low environment for interest
as well at the moment
but all you're taking on you've still
got to pay it back
uh and at the present time we've got
standard and pause looking at our
where our debt sitting and i think that
would really um
uh well would impact our debt profile
and potentially our ratings so another
things that are important to us
but we've also got to provide for the
future of our community i think our
community would be thankful to us
in delaying this at the time this time
we have
looked at our current building and we
are spending the minimum that we need to
um and upgrading the heating and
ventilation and making it a better
environment for our staff as well as
leasing
other pre-renting other premises in the
town to
alleviate some of those pressures not
ideal but it's also
helping out those building owners as
well they had
some of them had vacant premises so it's
overall helping
our local economy as well so
not ideal but at the present time i
think it's about presenting a
responsible and prudent position
when we know more and when we see where
our economy is at
then we can make some further decisions
at a later stage but at the moment
signalling what we do i think is the
responsible and prudent position
thank you i will reluctantly approve
this recommendation
with the proviso that we revisit once
the impact of three waters
on staffing is known um i've done quite
a bit of
um research and and i'm quite passionate
a bit like
council barnett that we
move forward in the future of the
library
civic precinct facility for
rengar at the hub of waimakariri
so but so i do understand that we're in
a
an unusual situation where we're
uncertain of the future with our
staffing requirements
and so i do see that we need to
wait and see see what happens in perhaps
the next 18 months
i just like to just some of my homework
that i've done at present staff has
spread all over the town
and i'm quite concerned about this this
is very much less efficient and costly
both in expenses rentals and costs alone
with the long-term decision to extend to
expire angular
farmers building which accommodates
roading planning alone a large number of
staff
there's quite a large cost here which
could go against repayment of
some of the overheads initial plans are
two that we were involved in are to
incorporate the library extension office
administration
community accommodation and museum in an
inviting one-stop experience
with perhaps retail continuation on high
street
and green courtyard spaces facing onto
percival street
with that being the main entrance for
all facilities still
allowing car parking west and south of
the buildings in
entrance connecting through to victoria
park
the final square metres could be
determined when we have the final
confirmation of the impact of the three
waters review
the library extension is long overdue
and must be in my opinion
a priority for the district before we ad
hoc spend monies on smaller projects
which could fragment the service rengar
is the central hub of the district and
needs upgrading as a priority
to bring the museum into the mix would
allow for central accommodation
and interest and we could expand the art
gallery
with a growing senior population more
retirement villages in the district
a central hub for most facilities would
be
ideal so um
i think that um roading is a large
commitment around 28 29
30 school bridge is not only in my view
and the eastern bypass
should be a priority as well so we we've
got a lot of expense
further out as well but anyhow
i will recommend this recommendation
so that we can be prudent and that we
can wait until we see the impact
of three waters and other other things
out of our control with stuffing
but i also would like to say that i
think we should fight to keep our staff
and these changes
thank you i i don't disagree with that
with what uh council waters said however
the time is not right
we've never been more certain about the
uncertainty in local government
and we know there will be change
it's going to happen for warned is
forearmed
and we need to be right at this time
more than ever
pretty careful about the capital
expenses that we commit
to our district yes money's cheap and
i'll hear those arguments you know
um i've already heard them this morning
from from a counsellor where
a statement made by a ceo yesterday
means we should spend all sorts of money
and
just do it now and make sure that we get
on with it because money's cheap
well we still have a responsibility to
people to be able to appear at the
affordability of this
of of where they live and the
affordability is important and racism
one of those
categories we will hear as soon as this
goes out that if we put the projections
are up yesterday so i stand to be
correct but i think
23 over the next 10 years will be the
will be the uh the rate rise you know
over over time i think it ended up
jeff's better that mean deals with
numbers every day but it
was around that figure so we're going to
hear all that
if we're not responsible with what we
we're going to do here
and there will be some ups and downs
some things we don't like and some
things we do like
but i look i have full sympathy with
them with a growing community in the
library that needs to be extended
but the one picture is actually um
is the right thing to do have a look at
what we did in kuaiboe
after the earthquake and
just about everybody i speak to talks
about how great that facility is
with a collective of things in it
the library the service center all of
those things the meeting rooms
people talk about how good for the
community
and for our district that that is we
need to do this once do it right
we don't have the ability to go out and
get a 30 million dollar
loan on the top of the capex that we're
already doing right at the moment to get
this stuff done
we can do that if you want to but
standards and pause will be looking at
us and going
yep we told you so here goes your rating
it's just not prudent to do that
and right at the moment with covert as
well now i mean i can argue
i've been sitting around this table for
nearly 20 years robbie's been here for
over 20 years
um you know every year there's a crisis
it's just the level of the crisis of
what you have to pay for but
what attention you have to pay to to
that crisis i've never lived in a
country in my life i'm
60 years old next week i've never lived
in a country in my life in fact i've
only ever lived in this one
i've never lived in one where all of a
sudden everything's shut down
that has never happened it is here goes
that word
unprecedented in the life of most of the
people
that sit around this this table and
most of the people in the district
wartime was the last time
they shut countries down you know we
have to be prudent with what we're doing
and be sensible because i
also to counter that i do not want to
live in a district that stands still
and i do not want to stop the growth
because people can't afford to come here
so it's a big balancing act and
unfortunately
this is one of those balancing acts that
just has to be pushed out a bit further
to make sure we've got it right
and that we're we're doing things right
but for me the one project
after what we didn't quite wear after
the earthquake for me
is actually something that is really
really relevant to this old exercise
and it does involve our staff but i just
remind you
we have never been more certain about
the uncertainty of local government
i'm quite uncomfortable with this
recommendation because i want to vote
for
part of it and i want to vote against
part of it which makes it very very
difficult
i want to vote for the office
accommodation being scheduled for 2028.
we cannot do that earlier
and it is too uncertain and i totally
agree with all the arguments that have
been put forward by other people
but i do not agree with deferring the
placeholder budget which is only a
placeholder budget
of seven million dollars um from 2024
to 2028 for the rangiora library
extension
and i voted against pushing it out
way back two terms ago when we voted on
the kaipoi library
the reason was that even when i started
in 2010 the rangiora library was
bursting at the seams
now that was 10 years ago now we had an
earthquake and we had to fix
all the things that were broken there
was no choice about that
but we spent 26 million dollars doing
that
and it wasn't the right time but we had
to we had to do it for our people
and as councillor atkinson has rightly
said the library
has become a hub that's become the most
important place
for people to meet for people to get
information it's
critical for a growing town centre to
have that facility
rangiora library is a dog and i don't
say that
it's not any reflection on staff it's a
historic building
that is no longer fit for purpose and i
am uncomfortable with coupling
the civic center with the library
upgrade
i'm very uncomfortable about that and
there's two reasons
for that the first reason is that
building accommodation of council staff
is always
wildly unpopular it's politically
suicide to put up a new building for
council staff
even though we desperately need it in
our outmoded building
this is always going to be a political
football it's going to come up at every
election it's going to come up at every
long-term plan it's going to come up at
every annual plan
why are you spending money on a council
building that is always going to be
difficult
to get through and in this environment
it's going to be impossible to get
through
with the uncertainties we're facing but
the library is a core
council function and we are not meeting
level of service
we are failing the people of rangiora
and the surrounding district
by having a library that is not fit for
purpose it does its best
with the facilities it's got and we
still like going there
but it's not fit for purpose for a
district
that's going to be reaching 100 000
people
um in the next 20 years and if we defer
it again
like we deferred it with the earthquakes
we defer it again
that placeholder budget we can't even
get the project started
now when you do big projects you stage
them and it's quite
normal to stage if we're doing a civic
precinct which is a
lovely aspiration and i love i love
council awards vision
although i don't actually agree with the
timing of it um
if we're doing a civic precinct you
stage it first stage for this
has to be the library and i do not agree
with pushing that budget out at the
moment
we've talked about covert people are
going to need
the library and community facilities to
get through covert
they're going to need a place they can
gather and meet
you cannot meet moringa library we can
push all the shelves around
and that will help but we cannot have a
decent meeting or function
in the in the rangiora library you can
in kanpur you can't and run europe
um people are looking for jobs people
are using the internet there
people go there to connect they go there
to learn new skills they go there to
make their gp's
it's not just about books it is a
community hub
and if we fail our community by not
having a fit for purpose community hub
in the largest town in our district then
we are failing them
as elected members so i cannot vote for
pushing out the library extension
i think the two projects need to be
decoupled
because i don't think we're going to get
the civic precinct through anytime soon
with the level of debt
and the level of uncertainty we've got
but the library
is essential the library needs to be
done and the time
is always going to be the wrong time to
spend capital money we said that about
the sports centre
and yet this council voted for it the
library is just as critical
for those who don't play sport it's for
those of us who need somewhere together
to connect to be people it's for
community development
so i'm i really
respect what everyone has said and i
respect the work that's been done in
this area
but personally i don't believe the civic
precinct will happen
and personally or certainly not in the
next
10 20 years and personally i don't
believe
that we should be coupling the library
project to store this project
that is well over joe and doing a
disservice to the
ratepayers of waimakariri
thank you i just take it back
not too many years ago when um around
this table
the council chose to just uh
do for the oxford library and service
centre
just to do a not a full
build a new build but just to replace
what needed to be replaced only to find
that they ended up having to do a full
build because of the
problems associated with it that full
build for the
live ulster library service center has
been nothing but an absolute
asset for our whole area for the oxford
community
and beyond and it is a meeting place
it can be used for all sorts of things
there's lots of children go in there
that have special meetings you've got
the home school children going in
it is absolutely an imperative that this
library is built and be built
for purpose and so i like
councillor um
again i'm actually yeah well i want to
call you cancel
kirsten um i really would like to see
this this
library get going and go ahead bring the
museum in on it
because that's really important because
the museum is
not fit for purpose anymore and i really
would like us just
to have a bit of pride in this
particular area
for those that those reasons and this is
why i will be voting very much for
the service center at library coupled
with a museum
ah thank you mr mayor i think it's
logical to align budgets for both the
library and the
civic centre we need a comprehensive
design and in my view
i agree with other colleagues that it
should also include the museum
i don't agree to a staged program
until we know more about what we're
going to end up with
i don't favour a piecemeal approach i
see it as a comprehensive development
including the three elements of the
library the civic centre
and the museum council award when i had
a talk to her the other day referred to
it as a one-stop shop
so i would like to see that happen the
only issue we have
is one of tyman council award would like
to see it sooner
in terms of the library so with council
avani
um but i think we do have to be prudent
and i see these still really as
placeholder
um points
in the budget um there are too many
uncertainties to make a commitment
to this project and i really want to see
them both
go together rather than be dealt with
separately
we also will shortly be discussing
measures to help the library
in the interim and i think that goes a
long way to addressing some of the
concerns that councillor barnett has
pointed out in a perfect world yes it
would be great to have a new library but
unfortunately we're in the real world we
do have budget constraints
and i think we have to be prudent but at
the end of the day
i think it's very desirable that these
projects being
treated together the only issue that
will come up for debate and we can look
at this in future years
is the timing and at the moment the
timing is not right
thank you
picked it off thank you
i'll just restart thank you thank you
ceo um i'm not denying that this is
ideal and
look and as we've all talked about in an
ideal world yes you would get on and do
these things straight away and
the consultation dot well within the
environment and as soon as we
see as practical but in the environment
we're in we've all talked of covert
and the uncertainty in local government
particularly
the consultation document will ask our
community
its viewing and so we'll listen to what
this goes out with referred position but
ideally we're always guided by our
community and
let's listen to what they've got to say
but there is a an element of this where
we need to go out
and show our community that we're
showing some leadership in that space
and what our
preferred position is and in in taking
into account all the information you
know but
it'll be part of that and we'll hear
from there um
but i think it was um i heard council
barnett referred to you before that the
libraries
it's a very unfortunate word because
actually it's not
um everyone i talk to in our community
always talks about what a fantastic
facility we have yes it's perhaps
reaching
its constraints and we know that but
paula you and your team
do an outstanding job you really do and
i know that our community
highly value that facility and all the
volunteers that go along and support
that and go to the volunteer functions
every year and they
always follow such pride for that
facility and we
address the heating um uh
through our last budget i hope that's
working better and this particularly in
this environment that's uh
a little warmer but i know that they
were very appreciative
of of us making that investment to
address that because
of and that's right it is considered by
a number as a meeting point and a hub
for a range of different reasons and
through covert particularly i was really
impressed with how you and your team
performed
in that space and made sure that books
were accessible in fact they went in
there on the sunday
and books were flying out the door we
weren't really sure if they were going
to come back but
i think they have but that's just the
way in which our library support but
look we do need to look at the broader
picture
i think coupling the two is still
important and we can consider that as we
go forward
and if we change our mind there's our
ltp
at the very least is going to be
considered within
three years uh further three years time
because it's always considered every
three years and
with what's in the picture at the moment
we may well be considering
that sooner um let's just see where that
goes but i think it is very important as
i mentioned before that
we do present to our community a
responsible and prudent position
noting that i'd like to do more but
we're just not in that position at the
moment but
please don't take that as a view that
our council doesn't value our library
because we do
question mr mir is it possible to take
point i am .2 secretly
this procedural question please
or can they be removed into a b and a c
perhaps
i'll move with i'll take a so that we
receive the report
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carry um we'll take
b1 all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
and then b2 always in favor please say
aye
contrary i declare that carried
counselling
okay all right thank you um
thanks jeff can i just
so we just now come to
4 12. so if we just go back into your
diligent and it's back in the main
reports
so just just give members a minute a
minute or two to
connect back in
see everyone got it cut it out oh page
um 308
tier 14. that's it's not in the white
pages it's intelligent on your computer
jane
uh sorry it's diligent page 308 tab 14.
so tab 14. so you need to go back into
the main you've got it does everyone got
it now
i'm not hearing otherwise so paula uh
your report please thank you
kyota koto happy new year
um so libraries are
seeking approval for the recommendations
and the report um if i can just refresh
everybody
we were talking about renewal of the
library kiosks the machines that issue
that enable our community to self-issue
the items they are borrowing
with a hundred and ten thousand dollar
tag price tag for the full replacement
of the network-wide kiosks that's seven
machines and three sites
c was reducing or
waiving fines for our young people so
currently
young people in the district
at the age of 16 they become an adult
the proposal
is for young people to be considered
until the 18th birthday and
no fines for anybody so the report i
spoke to in december stated that we
currently had just over 1 000
under 18 year olds with debt
starting at four dollars and above who
were not able to use
any library services including online
databases
which i'd like to say like to add has
huge implications in a lockdown
when schools were directing students to
use their local libraries electronic
resources through the epic consortium
which we're part of
and a block on their library card means
that they can't do that
in response to councillor redmond's
question yesterday about what the
library's
public library new zealand network
responded very rapidly to my question
asking what age group
other districts categorise young adults
and with exception of ashburton
who charge children from 16 but regard
them as a young adult until their 18th
birthday
to date from the data that i've had back
we are the only library
charging our young people and
categorising them in adult
at 16.
point c was for the provision of new
shelving um so stage one council granted
that money last year in the annual plan
stage two will be funded
from our fee waiver from the nzlpp
so approximately 40 000 of that will be
covered by central government
and we're asking for stage three the
final stage of the shelving replacement
at rangiora which is approximately 35
000
from the quotes i received last year
last year from two vendors
these shelves will be predominantly on
what
one significant portion will be on
casters to enable
us to create those spaces that we don't
currently
have for community gatherings for
workshops for lectures for presentations
for concerts for events
and make it easy for more staff than are
currently physically able
to move the existing shelving back at
the moment we do have
we do have an older workforce at
rangiora and
at times it is very limiting who can
physically move the shelving
point e is
just reiterating that the shelving
replacement phase 3
would be covered by the nz lpp the new
zealand library's partnership funding
the
58 million that central government gave
new zealand libraries last year
point f um is for
smart shelving so that is a refresher
that's the showing where you pop your
library item on it
it's rfid enabled and it's automatically
taken off your library account
the the benefit of this shelving means
we
reduce we we basically don't need the
existing real estate that's used
as a returns room and that can be
repurposed
into a community and council-wide
meeting
learning space um quite easily
and constant conversation with several
builders while the hvac system was being
installed i
took the opportunity to use the in-house
expertise
and then we actually brought in one of
the council contractors and checked a
few things with him
so point g refers
to the 20 000 estimated to modify the
existing returns room
if the smart shelves are granted freeing
up their space
for the meeting room that i've talked
about the cost for this
would be covered in this current year's
nz lpp fee waiver
so central government would be funding
the creation of that space
i'd like to just point out that i've
carefully considered that every request
is transferable into a new space
extension or library whenever that
happens
and even down to the glass walls
and doors that would be needed to frame
up
the new room would be relocatable
should a space that size be able to be
repurposed and an extension
in the future it's been really important
to me
that waimakariri
demonstrates that the value we get from
the ins the new zealand library's
partnership money is in line with what
the minister and national library
have envisaged i am very connected to
that working group so it's important to
me personally and professionally
and in conversations we are making sure
that we are demonstrating the role of
libraries and communities
in this community for existing library
users
but also those who don't see themselves
in the library at the moment
and for us to create space through
mobile shelving
or through a space a meeting room and
target those people who we don't
currently serve we have a
hugely loyal following but we also have
people that don't use the library for
different reasons for their stories
for their sense of belonging and we know
that in a covert environment
the opportunity to learn to up skill to
connect
the community hub message is coming
through so strongly here and i really
celebrate you all for that that's
a lot more than i hear from a lot of my
colleagues who talk to councils
the community commons is and community
hub idea
is very much we were at and um
i re i i think that using the nz lpp
unexpected one for that we've got for
the next two years in conjunction with
the three staff
we're going to be able to serve more of
our community those that love us for our
printed material
and those that need us to connect to
learn to engage
and so and just for well-being
i'll take questions thank you thanks
paula um
questions so we've got a recommendation
that someone prepared to move council
award signal by councilwecky
uh councilwood thank you paula
um yes i would thoroughly recommend
everything we need to do there to assist
you to
to to keep you going and um it's a
wonderful
community um facility the library and
you do a great job and the team are
great and your
everyone all the oldies that come
voluntarily they
they're super too so it's a great
community effort
and look forward to working closely with
you in the near future to extend your
library
council blacky
yes thank you paul yes thoroughly
recommend all your suggestions in this
budget
um the shelves and the in the smart
shelves are a no-brainer
i mean yeah obviously um
removing the youth phones um great great
great idea moving into the modern world
um it's a i think it's as you've pointed
out it's a major disincentive to get out
get our youth
engaged so good good on you for bringing
that into
um the self-service kiosks they have to
be done i'm not actually in
favor of those i worry that a a place
like a library which is a community hub
where you where human interaction is
very very important
every time you put a machine in it's it
you're losing a little bit of human
contact but that horse is bolted
the one the kiosk you've got to stuffed
so
you've got to put new ones in so all in
all a good prudent
butcher thank you council williams one
of our council meetings
yeah why do you think we've got one of
the best libraries in the
in the whole um community areas and
supporting actually it's really good um
you answered my question one one
biggest one was will i shelving and
likely you utilize when we do the
extensions
and so that that is really good so
just giving my support to um the
feedback i'm getting back from
rape cars uh we've got a good library
and we need to keep it
good and um so yeah real good thank you
yeah paula you said we've got about a
thousand
um under 18 currently with fines and
this deals with from one july onwards
would your view be if we were to
re um what would be the impact
or consequence of council remitting
the fines of those who currently are on
our books and
what would be your thought about that
that's a great question so selwyn
upper heart have recently had approval
to wipe fines for all their users
and based on a welcome back campaign
particularly at selwyn
existing debt was waived and
membership has been membership growth
new membership has been phenomenal
engagement with traditionally
non-library users people who might have
had a debt
when they were say 17 18 and then the
scale of the campaign
through facebook and social media and
the website and
and customer facing has brought people
back in the community engagement
so um impact there would obviously be
you could look at it as money not
gathered but actually most of the time
you're never going to get it anyway
statistically what does happen is you
get a lot of lost
books back because people don't have
this shame so
libraries often run in amnesty and when
amnesties run you get books back you
know you exchange fine for cans of food
for
for a charitable purpose that sort of
thing is quite common
some research that came out of san
francisco when they waved their fines
and did a complete amnesty
they got books back that had been 25
years overdue
so you know phenomenal amount of stock
back because there was no shame there
was no debt so a win-win-win
council i'd like to move an amendment
um i would like to move a through g
and also add an h
which would remove all current fines
and perhaps
perhaps it might be just simpler to um
amend c which would be um rather than
you talking about all fines and general
justice current fines that are standing
right now
and and commence an amnesty program
um as per
what i just said
what do you want to amend it into the
mind
get a little bit of guidance from paula
about how to frame this because there is
a difference between all
fines and all fines for people under 18
which is significantly different and
and if we were minded to how do you
think we should structure that to be
most effective from your perspective
thanks so can i just ask a couple of
questions are you seeing this
as zero to eight uh the eighteen
first the zero to eighteenth birthday or
are you seeing this for
all people of all ages what would be the
greatest benefit to our community in
your eyes
um if if i'm speaking honestly um find
free
debt-free fee waiver of every single
person in the district starting with a
blank canvas
um and a huge welcome back campaign
anna come and we're here to support you
because we don't know your story but let
us help you with it
that's that's kind of what i was we
would make headlines
um being
like just just sitting in the in the the
can we just
make just confine this to questions
first and
then we'll make sure that we've got it
framed correctly
yep did you have further questions nikki
because i'll come back to you in a
second
so i i think if if we if we framed it as
as that by going forward be fine free
for under 18.
but retain adults so we retain
adult fines going forward because we do
need to have a disincentive for people
to just walk out the door with our books
and never come back
so you just hold on yeah okay can we
just talk
do you have a question council worms yes
what sort of value would we be talking
okay so based on
um the last full non-covered year
because bearing in mind there was no
fines
for about six weeks after we came out of
lockdown because of
the national library consortium project
um we were talking approximately
5 000 for children and district wide
that's outs that's debt that we gathered
in the last non-covered year for
16 years and under and across
all demographics uh approximately 20 000
all up was gathered and that's the data
that i had
from ap and k it doesn't match with what
finance have said they think we bring in
less
and fine so there is a little
discrepancy i just wanted to declare
that honestly that
there's those two areas i would suggest
that
it is a a a waiver of fines
and um but lost items
are still lost items that we're not
giving up a blank canvas
for you to keep your box if you've kept
your book and not bought it back
that's fine bring it back and there is
no fine no penalty
you re you reuse your library card but
if that book
is lost and you're not able to find it
we
personally and from other libraries that
have done that i think we should still
if you've lost the book it's your
personal responsibility
if you've got your book and you don't
you can bring it back there's no charge
because yeah and the second question is
if this was bought in
would it encourage people to keep their
books longer
and not worry about any fine system um
statistically it doesn't happen
um that that's so there's it's quite a
political conversation as
you can imagine and the research from
overseas in particular who have
um in the states they've been leading
the way with this and sydney and
tasmania
it doesn't none of the data shows that
people do that
it's an opportunity to engage in the
conversation about you can renew your
library item
give us a ring let us set up the app on
your phone you can do it online
it's it's a re-education reconnecting
more of a we're here to work with you
but we don't want to work against you
and it's an amazing opportunity to
engage with your community in different
ways
um i i've discussed with the library's
leadership team that should we get any
of this through
that we would be front-facing in the
community we'll be at events we'll be at
supermarkets we'll have flyers on cars
we will be
shouting it from the rooftops that this
is what we're doing and encouraging a
welcome back campaign
the libraries and arts manager from
selwyn and upaha
are fully supportive of sharing what
they have done with me
because our three libraries have been
our three library districts have been
granted some of the most
most rewards from the lpp and we're
working together strongly
counselor brain followed by council
reckons
hearing in line this is a draft for
a consultation
between now and submissions would you be
able to supply a
policy paper articulating what you're
trying to verbalise at the moment
absolutely and that would include
obviously what was potentially called
cost
marketing campaign and what that might
that might cost
no problem so so just coming back so
you're
maybe an amendment which is effectively
a new age can you just reframe what that
said
that we
withdraw fines which are currently
standing
on under 18s and commence
a an amnesty program
for outstanding adult finds at this
point
yeah um let me just see i i feel like we
need to probably have
something in place do you want to do
so i just want an embassy for up to this
point for adults and then
and that that we have a report then
request a report
going forward um what the implications
um okay so so can we just
make sure we're clear so h what have you
got reported there
can i can i suggest a way forward too
because i think council of brian raises
some reasonable points
uh i'm just waiting to
with me and i wonder i i wonder
chris and paula whether for the march
council meeting whether this
meeting could request a report to
whether that's feasible in your timeline
absolutely a report to the march
council meeting that addresses the issue
of remission now you can deal with
remissions
outside of that annual plan
process so if you wanted to start a
remission campaign
yeah my thinking is if you wanted to
start a
a a remission and amnesty campaign
before the adoption of the ltp process
then you can that that is not
necessarily a matter for
annual uh ltp
per safe or debt other than the decision
you've made about
18 year olds onwards and you might want
the council might want to give effect to
that early but if
if it did that at its march meeting you
could get a report that sort of
shaped up what you'd like to do and how
best to give effect to
i think the sentiment that sits with the
council
and so the so the motion today or the
amendment today would be request a
report for the march meeting
on um on a live refine remission
how does that sound are you happy with
that yes i'm happy with that so you're
moving
you're moving that request what he said
request a report on library fine
remissions to the march council
meeting to come to the march council
meeting seconded
but so it's a new age and that's
seconded by
um how savannah council
yes i just want to make sure that that
report
also includes the cost of the campaign
yeah i think it would be a comprehensive
a report that
covers all aspects of how that would be
rolled out i think
if i can just share the cost of the
campaign more largely will mainly be
people
um the ncaa community coordinator role
will be largely at the centre of this
so thank central government and social
media the power of it
is already rostered within current
capacity
so we still need them anyway
i think these are mostly sunk costs
anyway so
they're bad that's written off just just
we'll be there in one second
so consultations but then it still
proposes
the budget is still the budget is still
just to be clear the budget from one
july will provide fourth fines for those
18 and over
and and we'll be asking for and
they still remain but for 18 and under
there
there will be no fines so that's the
budget position
what you do with the debt and the
amnesty would be a which is the current
debt and amnesty
as a matter for march now there's a
little bit that your report will need to
traverse is what we do between
what's the best thing to do between
march and july
for those who are under 18 and i can
imagine what we might think
is the right way to deal with that okay
so speaking to the amendment
customers paula you have many times
told us and and again today what the
effect is
on on that debt on on young people and
people in general we've seen how
important our community spaces are
particularly libraries
during covid at home learning
or you know finding new jobs etc
our libraries are community hubs and
they are probably one of the
very few free bastions where people can
can
actually get together and just be and
not be expected to spend money or do
something or move along in in a certain
amount of time
just recently at the gc2050 workshop so
there was a lot of talk about how people
need
particularly youth but you know people
just need a space where they can get
together
mean to be and not be expected right
your coffee is gone can you please free
up that table and um pay your bill
be gone you know we we need those places
and our libraries do that with regards
to
the improvements that you're proposing
for
for the kiosks and the shelving i think
that's very very clever the research
that you put into that
that the fact that these are going to be
transferable to the new facility
they'll make the job easier for now and
they're also going to make more space in
our very very full
facilities at this at this point so i
commend you on
your clever research on those
those products and i'm very happy to
support that as well but
you know the library is a central
part of our community and you do a fine
job
in looking after our people for us
and i'd like to make sure that you can
continue to do that into the future even
though we
cannot give you that the top of our wish
list which is
a new facility in the meantime i think
this is an excellent stop gap
yeah just speaking to the event
amendment about
um amnesty um
my children have lost books um i've
searched the house i've turned them
upside down and i
cannot find them and there is a shame
associated with that you go and you feel
really embarrassed
because you were responsible for that
book you took it out on good faith and
then you've lost the book
and luckily i've been in a position i
can make good but a lot of people aren't
and it's really really difficult when
when the budgets are really really tight
the other thing that you've got to
remember is that if an adult has a fine
they won't take their children so
therefore you're actually affecting the
lives of young people as well
so this is this is a chance for a fresh
start
it's a chance to reconnect with some
people whose lives may have changed in
the interim
but may have something historic that's
holding them back from reintegrating
with our community
and reintegrating their family with our
community so
i certainly think this would be a really
good move it's
an excellent move to show that we care
about our community
that we understand how hard these times
have been with
economic activity decreasing and i think
the timing is right and so i applaud
councillor mailings for
putting this in i applaud um the library
staff in paula for
looking after our community and i think
this is
a really good move to look at
a a wipe but still then educating those
people that they need to be responsible
going forward
okay uh council redmond this is speaking
to the amendment
correct mr mayor um i
i would like to well i am in support of
your amendment
uh wherever the amendment ended up um
i i in that report i'd like to see it
fairly comprehensive and
possibly we be given a number of options
such as are we waiving historical fines
for under 18s and or all users
including adults of course um
whether or whether we look at a fine
amnesty
for all users both children and adult
um whether we abolish fines for all
users
uh that's children and adults there are
a number of
options um and i must admit poorly your
passion for the topic has persuaded me
slightly that i'm more
sympathetic to remitting fines for all
users than i was when i came into this
meeting
i also ask and you've addressed it in
your report i think about the definition
a child if you like there was a
discrepancy between 19
and under and 18 and under so i think
we've now defined that so
when you come up with your report if
this amendment has passed
i would like to see a number of various
options it's not just one
blanket option but i think there could
be a number of choices that we could be
presented with thank you
thank you i'm also going to support the
amendment
if it had been as it was in the early
framing
um probably wouldn't have in the sense
because i would have liked to have
seen a report on it so i think seeing a
report on it with the various options i
think
is important because it you know there
is financial consequences and also the
message that
it seems but i watched through the as i
highlighted before in the discussion
through the covert um situation there
were books literally flying out the door
we had no idea
where they were going really and
from what you've advised vast majority
are back
so there is an honest system
honesty system within our community and
i'd like to explore that i think it's
worth
exploring so um like council savannah i
do applaud the
council meetings on requesting it and i
look forward to the report coming with
interest but
um i'm more persuaded than i like
councillor redmond probably
a little more persuaded than i was
earlier
after listening to what you had to say
and what i observed myself but
i would like to look at the broader
consequences of that
before making a final decision but we've
um so anyway any further speakers
okay we'll come back to the original
motion so i'll put the amendment
all those in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried so the amendment
now forms part of the original motion so
we're back
oh i'm sorry okay
h comes as father the recommendation so
the amendment is now passed
so h forms part of the original
recommendation
so so now um back to the original
recommendation is there any further
speakers
council duty well i'd just like to say
thank you
once again for your report it's
excellent
um and i'm very pleased that uh
we're going to move forward with these
this waving these fines and our
excellent
and and actually a waived fine has
has not lost money because you've never
had it so
i think it's a better lost item is
entirely different
so i think we're moving in the right
direction there too and i also like to
congratulate you on your forward
thinking
for things you can do in the library
that can be used again when we
have the opportunity to rebuild and i
really appreciate everything that you
and your staff have been doing thank you
okay any further speakers to the
original to the motion now yep
yep recommendation he's absolutely 100
in support of all the provisions in the
motion and they will
go some way to helping improve the
functionality of the library i'm excited
about the new space i didn't know about
that so that was great
um the
when i just wanted to clarify that when
i said the library's a dog i meant the
building
people say how wonderful our library is
because of the people
um you know they could have been in they
could be in a tin shed and they'd still
say it's a wonderful library because
we've got the most
fabulous staff um but there are sound
proofing issues i mean yesterday there
was babies crying they were teenagers it
was really hard to try and read my
council agenda
um you know there wasn't enough
separated spaces between youth and
adults and and there weren't quiet
spaces anywhere
because it's full and it's because it's
been used so much sometimes i can't get
a desk
um so you know it's really really a
critical
part of our infrastructure and it's why
it's really really important that we
make the best
use of it that we can so thoroughly
thoroughly support this recommendation
any further speakers council award would
you like to exercise or either reply
fine i think we're all in agreement
let's get on with it thank you
now put and i'll put that forward all
those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that caring thank you
paula
uh i think that we are due for winter
but i think we might just deal with the
white pages while we're here
i shouldn't well we'll see whether it
takes time so page 400 and
paula paul you'll need to remain for
your these are your budget papers
um yep so page 420
apart from what you've already
highlighted are there any other points
that you'd like
to draw to our attention
seems that i think most things have been
covered
there are some items there around
additional expenditure
so the additional items that were
identified
in relation to just taking a good look
at our existing costs our
existing budget and um and then real
costs and
in particular paper newspapers and
magazines and mr meal we've both
experienced recently
a custom community not being happy um
postage
is is currently for regional newspapers
three times
the cost of the physical newspaper and
despite um
extensive exploration of different
options
we're stuck with it and we are doing our
best to push the
community to digital but the demographic
loving the paper
um we've got to respect that too so that
accounts for
the additional expenditure for
newspapers and in magazines
with the dissolving
of many new zealand newspapers at the
beginning of covert
i did think that we wouldn't need this
but the
new zealand journalist the new zealand
journalism and magazine
industry is alive and well and new
titles that are really
uh pertinent and relevant to new zealand
and the regions are popping up all over
the place
so um we are hope we are replacing
titles um that were wiped
when the big overseas conglomerates took
us down
the circulation costs is never in my
time
and two years before i started being a
review of the
maintenance costs with the vendor who
provides the kiosks that accounts for
that additional money
i would like to say i may be able to
negotiate that out
with the new tender and i'll do my best
to not need that um
the blinds at roy tanifa
uh really to maximize the use of the
downstairs
area facing on to the key
it's obviously north west north
northwest facing
high sunlight and it does actually
reduce the
amount of use for that space we've got
all of that shelving on casters
and are using it for a public meeting
performance book launch
baby times trying to bring our events
downstairs instead of having them locked
away upstairs
but during many of the summer months
it's just impossible because the
sunlight is too much
so that was um from the team leader
at royalton if i would laura which i
fully support if it could get through
and that was really it we would we had
more on there but we've just tried to be
really prudent with
making the use of our existing spaces
better
we have looked at staffing and getting
staff to do more
and change the way they work
we were really aware that we didn't want
to ask for
anything that we didn't need this time
okay thanks paula questions i've got
councillor williams followed by council
blacky
two questions first one's a wee bit
tongue-in-cheek um
i presume that's 36 000 from newspaper
not 36 million
all the other ones are the same scenario
paul is always ambitious hope that would
get through
no yeah so
page 429 up at the top when you've got
circulation income
when you're so busy like you've been
saying
why is there basically a 10
reduction in the long-term budget 6 000
down to 60 000
my understanding of that is the impact
of the uh fines
that weren't gathered during covert
no no that's not um it's continuing up
all the way through you see
that would reflect what your new youth
fine component is
correct that's right thank you
yes reduction in income um making the
assumption that
the request for find free went through
so you can like circulation income is
derived from
best sellers from dvds cds
in any item that you pay for
as well as fines
reserve charges so um at the moment we
just have a one size fits all
everything is lumped together council
blackie
um question for chris um the blinds at
rue canafer have
have you have um the architect uh warren
and manny wasn't
have they been asked to comment on their
design and adequacies
um involving this um overheating problem
uh no
no they haven't um it's something which
uh we definitely need to be more mindful
of and the way we build buildings in the
future because i know that um we've
uh retrofitted blinds to the kuiper
aquatic center
um and then we're looking at doing the
same here um
they do have the the big veranda out um
the front but at certain times today the
light just still gets in and it's it's
really difficult to use the space so
they are needed to help us use this
space more and it's something that with
the
um indoor courts we've been um pushing
them on quite hard as well where
um they've got their computer models
which say that the sun won't get in and
it won't be an issue we've been saying
look
our experience is that blinds would
still be better
or stickers on the windows or whatever
they're
doing there so it won't be a problem
with the new building either
okay further questions council dirty
uh chris when uh when when the oxford
one i noticed you've got blinds on them
on the east side of
is that an afterthought as well or was
it was that done
i can't remember that was done straight
away
i think that was done straight away um
uh
however even though we've got blinds
they were also now planting trees on
that north side of the building in
oxford because you know the likes of the
staff
room just get so ridiculously hot um
i think we just need to turn the
temperature in oxford down a few degrees
and summer would help considerably thank
you but those blinds are
very effective okay thank you so there's
no further questions well
there's no there's no amendment because
we've uh to this
so this will be one's proposing one
because they we've moved to pro forma
motion at the start which approved all
the budget so
um is there any general i think we've
all had a fairly good
reflection on libraries so look paula
thank you and thank you to all you
to to all of your team uh what they do
and
um i think that's marked by the comments
that have been reflected to you today
so that's the library's budget so
we're going to break from morning tea
now and
say we're back at 5 to 11
and the next budget that we'll be
talking
about is aquatic facilities so i
mentioned is